E
SECONDS, THANKS, BRET HAVE.
A GOOD WEEKEND.
>> Bret: SEE YOU.
>> Jesse: FOX NEWS ALERT.
NANCY PELOSI'S HUSBAND PAUL
PELOSI WAS BEATEN IN THE HEAD
WITH A HAMMER INSIDE THEIR SAN
FRANCISCO HOME AT 2:30 IN THE
MORNING.
>> A MAN BROKE INTO HIS HOME,
THE HOME HE SHARES WITH HOUSE
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI, WHO WASN'T
HERE AT THE TIME.
BUT THAT MAN BROKE INTO THE HOME
AND ATTACKED HIM WITH A HAMMER.
HE SUFFERED BLUNT FORCE TRAUMA
TO HIS HEAD AND HIS BODY
EXPERIENCED SOME BRUISING AND
OTHER INJURIES BUT, AGAIN, IS
EXPECTED TO FULLY RECOVER.
IN THE MEANTIME, WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AT THE
LOCAL AND FEDERAL LEVEL
INVESTIGATING CONTINUING TO
GATHER EVIDENCE.
>> Jesse: HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW.
PAUL PELOSI JUST CAME OUT OF
BRAIN SURGERY AND IS EXPECTING A
FULL RECOVERY ACCORDING TO HIS
DOCTORS.
HE SUSTAINED A FRACTURED SKULL
AND SERIOUS INJURIES TO HIS
RIGHT ARM AND HANDS.
POLICE ARRESTED THE ALLEGED
ATTACKER, A 42-YEAR-OLD WHITE
MALE NAMED DAVID DEPI.
ILLEGAL YEN FROM CANADA.
A LONG HISTORY.
ELDER ABUSE AND SLEW OF OTHER
FELONIES BUT WASN'T DEPORTED.
SAN FRANCISCO IS A SANCTUARY
CITY.
THE SAN FRANCISCO CHRONICLE SAYS
IS HE A NUDIST ACTIVIST WHO
MAKES HEMP JEWELRY AND HE HAS
BEEN POSTING CRAZY SCREEDS ON
THE INTERNET FOR YEARS.
I READ THROUGH A FEW OF THEM AND
HE LOOKS MENTALLY ILL.
CNN REPORTS HE WAS HOMELESS
SLEEPING IN THE STORAGE SHED AND
ADDICTED TO NARCOTICS.
A FEW FORMER ACQUAINTANCES TOLD
CNN HE WAS OUT OF TOUCH WITH
REALITY, SO, IN SUMMARY HE WAS A
MENTALLY ILL HOMELESS NUDIST
ILLEGAL ALIEN EX-CON DRUGGY WHO
SHOULD HAVE BEEN DEPORTED.
POLICE SAY AT 2:27 A.M. TODAY
OFFICERS WERE DISPATCHED TO
PELOSI'S HOME RESPONDING TO A
WELL-BEING CHECK THAT WAS
CALLED.
IN POLITICO REPORTS THAT PAUL
PELOSI WAS ABLE TO DIAL 911
HIMSELF AFTER TELLING THE
INTRUDER HE HAD TO GO USE THE
BATHROOM AND THEN CALLING FOR
MAYOR WHERE HIS PHONE WAS
CHARGING.
SOURCES TOLD ABC NEWS THAT HE
BUSTED IN THROUGH A SLIDING
GLASS DOOR AND SAID WHERE IS
NANCY.
ACCORDING TO CNN HE TRIED TO TIE
UP PAUL PELOSI AND SAID HE WAS
GOING TO WAIT FOR NANCY TO COME
HOME.
POLICE HAVE NOT CONFIRMED THAT
AND SAY THEY HAVE NOT YET
DETERMINED A MOTIVE.
THIS IS WHAT THEY SAY THEY SAW
WHEN THEY ARRIVED.
>> WE ENCOUNTERED AN ADULT MALE
AND MRS. PELOSI'S HUSBAND PAUL.
OUR OFFICERS OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION MR. PELOSI AND
SUSPECT BOTH HOLDING A HAMMER.
OF THE SUSPECT PULLED A HAMMER
AWAY FROM MR. PELOSI AND
VIOLENTLY ASSAULTED HIM WITH IT.
>> Jesse: THERE WAS A LITTLE
CONFUSION ABOUT THE HAMMER.
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS THAT PAUL WAS
STRUGGLING WITH HIM OVER CONTROL
OF THE HAMMER.
JUST ONE HAMMER AND WAS HIT WITH
IT AS POLICE ARRIVED.
THE PERP HAS BEEN CHARGED WITH
ATTEMPTED HOMICIDE.
ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY WEAPON.
ELDERLY ABUSE, BURGLARY AND A
FEW OTHER CHARGES.
WHAT HAPPENS IN THESE TYPES OF
CASES USUALLY IS THAT WHEN THE
SMOKE CLEARS, SOME OF THE
INITIAL REPORTING IS WRONG,
WHICH IS WHY WE ARE TELLING YOU
WHAT NEWS ORGANIZATIONS IS
REPORTING WHAT BECAUSE THAT
COULD CHANGE BY TOMORROW.
THE PELOSI FAMILY IS NOT
TALKING, ASIDE FROM THE
STATEMENTS THAT THEY HAVE
RELEASED AND SAN FRANCISCO
OFFICIALS ARE NOT LEAKING TO FOX
NEWS.
JUST ABOUT EVERYBODY ELSE, IT
SEEMS LIKE.
BUT LIKE CLOCKWORK, THE MEDIA IS
REPORTING THAT THIS IS
JANUARY 6TH ON THE WEST COAST.
>> BEFORE THE ASSAULT OCCURRED
ACCORDING TO A SOURCE THE
INTRUDER CONFRONTED MR. PELOSI
IN THEIR HOME SHOUTING WHERE IS
NANCY?
WHERE IS NANCY?
DEBBIE DINGELL THAT'S WHAT THE
INTRUDERS GOING THROUGH THE
HALLWAYS ON JANUARY 6TH WERE
SHOUTING, NANCY, NANCY.
THIS IS PART OF THE JANUARY 6TH
INSURRECTION TOXICITY THAT HAS
INFECTED THE BRAINS OF PEOPLE
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
>> Jesse: SO THE NEW HOMELESS
CANADIAN DRUG ADDICT WITH A RAP
SHEET A MILE LONG MAKES HEMP
BRACELETS IS A JANUARY 6ER?
I THINK WE MAY BE GETTING A
LITTLE BIT AHEAD OF OURSELVES
HERE.
WE WISH PAUL PELOSI A SPEEDY
RECOVERY.
WE FEEL TERRIBLE FOR HIM AND OUR
HEART GOES TOUT NANCY AND THEIR
FAMILY.
SEE THIS HAMMER MAN LOCKED UP TO
20 YEARS TO LIFE AT LEAST.
THE MEDIA IGNORED THE A BLACK
LIVES MATTER AND ANTIFA RIOTS
CALLED THEM JUSTIFIED AND MOSTLY
PEACEFUL.
NEVER BLAMED BERNIE WHEN A
BERNIE BUREAU SHOT UP STEVE
SCALISE.
A LEFT WING ASSASSIN NEARLY TOOK
THE LIFE OF BRETT KAVANAUGH
AFTER THE SCOTUS LEAK AND
DEMOCRATS STILL DIDN'T WANT TO
ADD PROTECTIONS TO JUSTICES
HOMES.
THE REPUBLICAN CANVASSER JUST
HAD HIS JAW BROKEN AND THE MEDIA
BLAMED HIM.
AND WHEN RAND PAUL GOT HIS RIBS
CRACKED BY HIS CRAZY NEIGHBOR,
IT WAS ONE OF MSNBC'S FAVORITE
STORIES.
>> NEW DETAILS TODAY ON THE
INCIDENT THAT LEFT SENATOR RAND
PAUL WITH SIX BROKEN RIBS.
THIS MIGHT BE ONE OF MY FAVORITE
STORIES.
>> Jesse: EVEN PELOSI'S DAUGHTER
SAID RAND PAUL DESERVED IT.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN TELLING
US FOR YEARS THAT CRIME ISN'T A
BIG DEAL AND IF YOU TALK ABOUT
IT YOU ARE RACIST.
>> WE ARE DEALING WITH ACTUAL
CRIMES, THOSE EIGHT HOMICIDES
AND WE ARE DEALING WITH THE
PERCEPTION OF FEAR, THAT PEOPLE
ARE FEELING.
>> REPUBLICAN POLITICS, THE
ISSUE OF CRIME, AND THE ISSUE OF
IMMIGRATION HAVE LONG BEEN
PROXIES FOR RACE PLAYING THE
RACE CARD.
>> I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THIS
DOESN'T DRIVE HYSTERIA.
>> THE PERCEPTION IN THIS CASE
COUNTS MORE THAN THE ACTUAL.
>> PART OF THE REPUBLICAN
PLAYBOOK AS YOU WELL KNOW IS TO
POINT A FINGER AT LARGE DIVERSE
CITIES AND SAY LARGE DIVERSE
CITIES ARE LAWLESS.
WHAT WE SEE HERE IS THE SAME OLD
PLAYBOOK, WHICH IS ABOUT CODED
AND RACIST MESSAGING.
>> Jesse: THE DEMOCRATS AND THE
MEDIA HAVE BEEN IGNORING THE
CRIME WAVE AND ONLY COVER IT
WHEN NANCY PELOSI'S HUSBAND IS
ATTACKED?
WHERE IS THE MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS
BEEN WHILE THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS HAVE BEEN ATTACKED?
PEOPLE ARE BEING HIT WITH
HAMMERS EVERY DAY.
PEOPLE ARE BEING PUSHED INTO
SUBWAYS, SLASHED, SHOT IN COLD
BLOOD.
BUT THE MEDIA FOCUSES ON THIS
ONE SINGLE CRIME TO PEN IT ON
REPUBLICANS?
COME ON.
THE DEMOCRATS DEFUNDED THE
POLICE IN SAN FRANCISCO.
THE DEMOCRATS SANCTUARY POLICIES
PREVENTED THE GUY FROM BEING
DEPORTED.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO SEND
SOCIAL WORKERS TO WELFARE CHECKS
INSTEAD OF COPS.
IF THEY HAD SENT A SOCIAL WORKER
HERE, BOTH PAUL AND THE SOCIAL
WORKER WOULD PROBABLY BE DEAD.
PEOPLE IN SAN FRANCISCO WERE
SMASHING PEOPLE IN THE HEAD
EVERY DAY AND THEY GET BAILED
OUT.
AND THEY DON'T GET HIT WITH
ATTEMPTED MURDER CHARGES.
MAYBE THEY GET SENTENCED TO TWO
YEARS OF RESTORATIVE JUSTICE.
BUT THEY THROW THE BOOK AT THIS
GUY BECAUSE PAUL IS MARRIED TO A
POWERFUL WOMAN?
IT'S NOT RIGHT.
EVERY VICTIM SHOULD BE TREATED
EQUALLY AND SO SHOULD EVERY
PERP.
THE CRIME WAVE IS FINALLY COME
TO NANCY PELOSI'S HOUSE.
HOPEFULLY, OUR POLITICAL LEADERS